policing europe's banks can make her one
of the most powerful women in the world
is this the future banking supervisor
danielle newey was grilled by meps ahead
of a vote at the december plenary to
endorse her or not the single
supervisory mechanism expected to come
into force in 2014 will watch over
europe's 6 000 banks the success of the
ssm depends on the quality of the
cooperation between its different
components looking now beyond the ssm
achieving the integration of the largest
supervisory authority in the world in
the global community of banking
supervisors
is of utmost
importance
europe is a major transit destination
for illegal wildlife products from
countries like china and south east asia
with some 90 elephants slaughtered by
poachers every day in africa meps from
the environment committee are calling
for europe to take action now before our
tigers lines and elephants become
extinct the pace with which
we are plundering uh earth wild wildlife
is is really unprecedented so um
the the problem is extremely urgent
and i hope that if the european union
puts its
weight behind it we can
avoid that our children have to
go to a museum to see what an elephant
was like
not long after ukraine shut down a deal
for closer cooperation with europe
lithuania plays host to an eastern
partnership summit in its capital
tomorrow's summit will be an important
step forward in the development of the
eastern partnership
and will witness agreement
on a significant number of deliverables
ranging from initial link of association
agreements
including deep and comprehensive free
trade areas with georgia and moldova to
transport agreements the eu's eastern
partnership is designed to enhance
political and trade relations with
former soviet countries partnership made
tricky by russia's continued influence